das macht mich jetzt schon etwas
nachdenklich ist künstliche intelligenz
kurz ki menschlich einer neuen
forschungsarbeit zumindest nach
übernimmt kein tatsächlich menschliche
eigenschaften welche das sind und warum
sie wirklich gefährlich werden können
das jetzt den klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen der berühmte
physiker stephen hawking hat es
vielleicht vorher gesehen er sieht
künstliche intelligenz als bedrohung für
die menschheit zitat da der mensch durch
langsame biologische evolution
beschränkt ist könnte er nicht
konkurrieren und würde verdrängt werden
so hawking in der financial times die
künstliche intelligenz würde den
menschen sehr schnell überholen und eben
verdrängen
so prognostiziert hawking schon heute
verdränge die informationstechnologie
und die rationalisierung durch sie den
menschen
zitat die internet unternehmen müssen
viel mehr machen um dieser gefahr zu
entgegnen meint rocking die entwicklung
auf dem gebiet der künstlichen
intelligenz schreitet aber immer weiter
voran und sie ist offenbar nicht unter
kontrolle diesen schluss lässt
jedenfalls eine forschungsarbeit der
princeton university in den usa zu
wissenschaftler um den studienleiter ale
in kellys kennen haben nämlich
festgestellt dass die künstliche
intelligenz an gewohnheiten von menschen
übernimmt und die sind nicht unbedingt
die besten können sich die intelligenz
wird in form von programm mit unendlich
viel daten gefüttert und dazu gehört
auch eine unmenge an text so lernt die
software klo wie anhand von texten
wörter und setzt sie in beziehung
zueinander irgendwann weiß sie zum
beispiel dass mann und frau im selben
verhältnis zueinander stehen wie
youtuber und youtube
das problem an diesen texten ist dass
sie von menschen geschrieben wurden und
die haben vorurteile das forscherteam
hat jetzt das gelernte von glowe
überprüften ist dabei auf aus meiner
sicht wirklich erschreckendes gestoßen
dazu haben die forscher den impliziten
assoziations test eingesetzt er wird in
der psychologie verwendet um stereotype
erwartungen zu finden das heißt wer zum
beispiel männer grundsätzlich als
aggressiv empfindet wird jedes
männergesicht als aggressiv deuten
bei diesem thema
müssen begriffe kombiniert werden zb
kissen und angenehm oder kaktus und
schmerzen und so weiter anhand der
wortkombinationen der probanden können
jetzt vorurteile gefunden werden und bei
glow wie wurden sie gefunden und das
finde ich wirklich schlimm
der algorithmus war ein rassist und
hatte einen diskriminierende
grundeinstellung und das ist einfach
furchtbar typische vornamen von
afro-amerikanern waren für die software
eher unangenehm und typische sehr
angenehm
die software hatte alle vorbehalte aus
den eingespeisten texten übernommen und
es zeigt zum einen wie verbreitet diese
vorurteile überall sind und wie leicht
sie übernommen werden können ein trost
ist dass dieser fehler in dieser frühen
phase der entwicklung aufgefallen ist
und es hält uns den spiegel vor
ich finde das ist auch die gefahren sehr
frühzeitig klar macht ich denke das ist
jetzt ganz offensichtlich ist wir
brauchen eine sehr strenge kontrolle der
ki forschung ähnlich der in der
genforschung
wenn wir so weiter machen sind wir
vielleicht schneller als uns lieb ist
weg vom fenster ich halte euch hier über
ki auf dem laufenden wenn er dazu und zu
allen anderen themen kein video
verpassen wollt dann sollten wir hier
ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht mehr ein auf die
glocke zu geben und hier sind übrigens
die videos die er verpasst habt wenn ihr
bisher noch nichts klicks um abonniert
habt also sagt einmal durch das sicher
das ein oder andere interessante video
dabei also bis dann bleibt dran